quisiera preguntarle primero desde su
punto de vista cómo transcurrieron los
comicios
bueno muy buenas tardes gracias a ti
santiago bien todo tuviese a por la
oportunidad un gran desafío para la
unidad democrática para los partidos
políticos que hacemos vida en el canje
en la situación en que se encuentra la
democracia en este momento en nuestro
país la participación lo asumimos como
un desafío como una especie de parada en
el camino que hemos decidido es que es
el rescate del voto desde la
participación un proceso muy complejo
lleno de una gran disparidad de un gran
ventajismo por parte del régimen pero
estamos convencidos de que debemos
seguir creciendo organizándonos para
seguir avanzando ahora juan carlos la
observadora de la misión europea
advirtió sobre irregulares pero no dejó
de destacar también que fueron mejores
comicios que otros anteriores coincide
usted con esto
bueno el problema acá es que como lo
hemos dicho uno tiene que ver la
totalidad del proceso electoral y el
proceso electoral venezolano está
manchado de su comienzo cuando se
inhabilitan al partido político y no se
les permite participar con su tarjeta
cuando se inhabilitan a los principales
candidatos con mayor potencialidad del
triunfo desde el punto de vista
administrativo inclusive a días antes
del proceso electoral sin habilitar un
candidato que sólo recogen información
europea cuando hablan de la situación
del poder judicial y su dependencia al
estado pero también tenemos que recordar
que la misión de observación electoral
europea fue objeto de un proceso y
fuerte
campaña de amedrentar en tu de
calificación por parte de lo más alto 20
del régimen durante las últimas dos
semanas se dedicaron constantemente a
agredirlos y atacarlos para como de
seguir haciendo la descalificación a
priori del informe que obtenía luego al
señalar una cosa que es muy importante
que es el uso abusivo de los recursos
del estado de aquiles no se compite
contra el partido el partido vecino se
compite contra el partido hecho gobierno
y con el uso abusivo y declarado de los
recursos de estado y eso por supuesto
éste dificulta aún más la lucha que
estamos dando hay cosas importantes del
informe que es el que señalaron por
ejemplo la presencia de los puntos rojos
punto rojo para que lo entiendan la
audiencia son todos los que se pongan
los muy cerca de los centros electorales
y son puntos de agitación política de
parte de los de las personas que apoyan
al partido
de gobierno y esto por supuesto genera
amedrentamiento hacen que la gente pase
por allí a registrarse para poder
entonces garantizarle tu beneficio
social ya viste la voluntad de comida y
luego la situación de los medios de
comunicación señaló claramente lo que es
el ventajismo de esta lado de la
cobertura del partido gobierno y cierto
es ciertos aliados que tienen aquí en en
la cobertura de campaña en los medios
luego la situación de los cierra los
centros la ley venezolano establece
claramente que estaban a las seis de la
tarde y en muchos centros que estén
electores en cola los mantienen abiertos